saffron called good morning to you and
thank you so much for being with us so
NHS leaders saying the disruption is far
from over what are the next couple of
days and weeks going to be like
we're in for
um a challenging time over the next
couple of days because what we do know
is after this kind of strike action or
after something like a bank holiday in
the NHS we know that there is a lot of
pent-up demands so although yesterday
with the ambulance service strikes
things perhaps the demand was down what
we are going to see now is demand really
Rising so I think emergency departments
particularly are going to feel the
strain in those areas where there were
strikes which for ambulance services was
in every part of the country apart from
the east of England so some real
pressure there pent-up demand and also
the added pressure of rearranging all of
those operations and appointments that
needed to be postponed and what's that
going to mean for patient safety
I think we we should be assured that
trust trust leaders would do everything
that they can to make sure that patients
remain as safe as possible so that will
mean making sure that there are as many
staff as possible in those emergency
departments and making sure that
those operations can be
rearranged for as quickly as possible so
yeah it's going to be a challenging time
but the one thing that's really
important for the public and patients to
understand is that trust leaders do
everything in their power to to make
sure that patients are kept as safe as
possible I mean you mentioned it being
sort of the bounce back afterwards like
a bank holiday but you'll know
anecdotally many people who work in the
NHS say Staffing levels mean that every
day is almost like a bank holiday
because they are so understaffed I mean
where does this get resolved at this
point do you think now
I think you're absolutely right in terms
of those fundamental levels of Staff
shortages these structural issues that
we talk about stuff on the front line
are are significantly overstretched and
we need to see a real growth in the
number of Staff across the whole of the
NHS what we've got to see now is the
government come to the table and have a
serious discussion and negotiation about
pay because this dispute is about pay
and it's also about working conditions
and keeping patients safe and we know
what they're going to say about pay
that's for the independent pay review
board but let's talk about the working
conditions
I took a look at the um NHS provider's
website it says one of the missions is
to provide builds effective
relationships with central government
key stakeholders in central government
is there any feeling among energy
providers that that relationship has not
been working functionally after all this
time that we've reached this point
no I don't think that's fair to say our
role is to make sure that the government
understands the impact of its policies
and seek to encourage it to improve
those policies in the interests of the
NHS and the patients that it it it's
there to treat so I don't I wouldn't say
that they're broken down in in any way
we're there to really you know nudge
them and keep them going and focused on
on on the task in hand so we will
continue to do that and I think that
after the significant disgr disruption
we saw last week
um and this week and we're going to see
next week with with the ambulance strike
again and the possibility of strikes
being announced in in the new year I
think what we've got to do is make sure
that we stay completely focused on
making sure that the government
understands the importance of coming to
the table and understands the importance
of making sure that we're in a situation
where we can boost the level of Staffing
across the HS and also make sure that
Frontline staff get the pay terms and
conditions they deserve and I'm not
trying to be unfair as different as you
as you'll understand but I do want you
say nudge them I wonder if all sizes
need a bit more of a shove
it's my choice of language
absolutely and
very clear about
of what is going on at the moment where
that's come from and what we actually
need to do in future to make sure that
we have adequate Staffing across the NHS
we know that there are a hundred and
thirty thousand well more than 130
000 vacancies in the NHS we know that we
are hemorrhaging staff because of pay
and working conditions particularly in
more Junior bands of NHS staff so we
really have to do something about that
and it's not just about the NHS the
government knows we need to do something
about social care as well because social
care is really on its knees and it needs
a boost and if the if social care has a
boost then the NHS Frontline staff have
the terms and conditions they need then
we will see an effective NHS yeah and it
comes down to funding again doesn't it I
mean the health sector yesterday was
talking about extra funding to improve
outcomes and treatments but without
having a staff to to carry out those
treatments and services you're not going
to be able to a functioning service I
mean how much more money does social
care need to to get it functioning to
then help the health care sector I think
social care needs a very significant
check
injection and it needs also some
structural funding Support over a
significant period of time the way that
social care is funded is very much
there's there's a central funding pot
but then is also social care is funded
through local council tax so it's up to
the discretion of local councils as to
how high they set their What's called
the social care precept so it's it's a
very variable funding source so I think
we we need to see some significant focus
on that to make sure that it's
sustainable and fit for purpose and we
know that that local government has
struggled over the years with with
funding that has been depleted by up to
60 over the last 10 years or so so
that's very very difficult to run the
high level of services that they need to
run to support social care in children
in adults in vulnerable adults and older
people and you know that's a tough task
for them yeah and finally then saffron
quadri with all that we're facing in the
Health Service
um how worried are you about how it's
going to fare through this winter
we've known even even with the
industrial action we we knew that we
were in for a a tough time and NHS
Frontline stuff are incredibly
ingenious they are incredibly creative
Innovative trust leaders will be doing
all that they can to put plans in place
and we know that they work very closely
with NHS England and others to do that
but it's going to be hard demand is very
high Staffing levels aren't where they
should be and we know that we've got flu
which is causing Rising levels of
hospitalizations we've got mental health
waiting lists which is going through the
roof we've got covid coming back now and
we've just had a really cold snap so if
we have another one of those that's
going to add into the pot so we are
seeing a really tough situation here I
mean NHS staff will do everything they
can to get through this and to support
patients and to provide us safer care as
possible but we know it's going to be
tough
okay suffering quotery uh interim Chief
exec of NHS providers do appreciate your
time this morning thank you very much
thank you